say well one woman born into Islam who
when exposed to freedom and when after
she benefited from it did not forsake
her you know her contemporaries by
selfishly enjoying it and keeping it to
herself but by sharing you know how
ideas with them so my idea is not to
tell all Muslim women you should leave
Islam they should find their own path
each individual should find his or her
own path to freedom but what I have done
is share my experiences with them and
say I don't think every time when I was
an interpreter translator in Holland I
would be confronted with a woman who was
beaten bruised killed almost killed I
would feel helpless and I would
understand the mechanism and the code
and I wouldn't know what to do about it
but by saying I think it is possible to
get a very difficult extremely difficult
and some of us will die but it is
possible to make a change I think I've
made my contribution but it is up to the
individual Muslim woman to find her way
out of it